[Music]
it's okay Gwen you can do it while we
fly here but anyone could see me no
one's watching Gwen you know what I'll
go up front what's happening we have a
number two situation oh everything okay
back there sorry my bad my
bad mom I can't do it here can we land
we won't land Gwen you're old enough to
do it in the sky now but it's too much
pressure and it's gross it's not gross
we're Birds every bird does it in the
sky what if someone is looking down
there no one is looking down there I
told you we are not Landing there is no
way we're
Landing are you sure no one's watching
when Mard do it now or we leave without
you okay okay oh she's perfectly capable
of doing her business in the sky and yet
here we are let her be does anybody have
a soft Moss just just use a leaf Dad
we're not really going to leave him here
are we he looks so cramped in that cage
come on blow it
out
what there's nothing we can do here Dax
we could get the key no kid that's
impossible why where is it down
there the chef keeps that key on him at
all times and trust me you don't want to
go anywhere near that lunatic
in catcha him turn you into duck laange
what duck laange it's you with L on
top you did it I can't believe it I was
in a cage and now I am not in and now
not and you did it all of you but you
your wild duck you you must be the
bravest duck We Ever Meet oh I'm not
that I'm not that brave what you knew
the danger you did it anyway what do you
call that yeah you're right I guess that
is the only word that describes who I am
did you hear that he call me Brave so
you want to go to My Island eh I will be
honored to take it in myself huh you do
that for you me don't anything because I
can do
anything woohoo I can go here or I can
go here free as a bird but cuz I'm a
bird are you sure you have to go already
I miss your kids so much they are so
adorable and you taste so good maybe
I'll eat you I'm
kidding where am I
uh it's a joke it's a
joke
funny all right time to go thanks for
everything goodbye I have a guitar
goodbye no no no no no no blow him a
kiss no no no no you don't have to walk
closer you're good
there come on we got to get ready ma
ready for what nothing just you know for
our big super fun family migration what
ha but you didn't see that coming are
you serious yep an adventure into the
totally
unknown and I'm going to love it wo wo
wo wo wo wo is this real what do you
mean is this real we're really going yes
on a migration to Jamaica yeah together
like everyone including you yes we are
all going on a migration to Jamaica and
which language should I tell you thanks
Dad you're
welcome
I knew there was some Adventure left in
you wait wait
wait here we are
together we're on an
adventure seeing what else life has to
offer is that a little scary sure but
isn't it worth
it we're not going to make it are we
Uncle
Dan what is this place we are completely
lost was your
mother that is not your
mother we're trying to get to
Jamaica don't worry Chum's got you so
listen Chum what did you just call me
sorry I thought your name was Chum yeah
chump yeah that's my name what right so
listen Chum what did you just call me
I'm sorry is everyone else hearing
chump
what
[Music]
this isn't about migration it's about
Adventure w w wo who
hey what just happened I don't know but
you're in
trouble what is that dange what's
dange it's you with laange on
top there's a whole world we've been
missing out on and
we when danger
strikes you do not run from it
reload we're going to finish this crazy
wonderful
[Music]
Adventure you're so
adorable maybe I'll eat you I'm
kidding where am
[Music]
I go go
[Applause]
go here we go gosh this is it guys that
is so good
yeah migration is about relationship
within the family of ducks it's really
funny and special they must be migrating
we're going to Jamaica I really want to
see that I want to go to Jama with they
make jam the f is really protective with
his family and at some point he realized
that actually the family wants more I
don't want to miss out on life because
you're afraid to leave this Pond they
need to discover the world let's
fly
hey wo yeah
wo what do they do rip you apart then
eat you D I don't know how they do it
what's the method I was so lucky on the
casting hi there I'm Pam I'm sharing my
life with him so I'm painfully aware of
all the stupid things that come out of
his mouth oh yeah that's true she
is just sit close to me and everything
will be all right they all so great and
is this a session where you're just
tired of laughing because you laugh so
much we're trying to get to Jamaica ah
yeah yeah that's in Queens right uh more
[Music]
south the whole theme is about this
journey to discover the world and
embracing life this isn't about
migration it's about Adventure Whatever
You're Expecting over there it's going
to be even
[Music]
better now get out there and have some
fun
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah